[Music]
foreign
there we go
very good
hey everyone
thanks for joining us we're going to get
started in just a few seconds we're
going to give folks a few seconds to pop
in
happy Wednesday
wherever you are drop where you're
coming from in the chat
I'm from Philadelphia and my colleague
is from Vancouver
I don't know
very good let's get going
um so before the presentation just some
helpful information the recording of
this presentation will be available
right here immediately following the
presentation
you can put questions in the chat or you
can ask them anonymously through our
slidolink for more information about
Academy because we can only cover so
much in this period of time just go to
posit.co backslash Academy and we
already got a question about this so I
want to call out posit Academy is
currently only offered to groups of
Learners we're working through how to
expand the offering but the group
experience is a core part of the academy
experience so it again it's currently
offered only to groups of learners and
if you're not familiar with Academy we
introduced posit Academy to the world
last year for groups who want to learn
are and we're thrilled to have recently
introduced python curriculums which is
why we're here so the presentation is
great for folks who are unfamiliar with
Academy this is a great sort of
introductory presentation groups of data
professionals who are interested in
exploring training Solutions and
organizations that want to become more
data driven specifically with code-based
data science so R and python with all
that said I'll hand the presentation
over to my colleague Daniel Chen who is
a data science educator on the posit
team
all right
all right um hello everyone
um good day so I'm Daniel I'm currently
a postdoctoral teaching fellow at the
University of British Columbia and I am
also a data science educator here at
posit
and so I wanted to start off today by
just doing a quick answer of why you
should learn python
and the short answer is it's python is
just objectively popular so it's ranking
number one here on the topi index and
it's above languages like C C plus plus
and JavaScript so it is a very popular
programming language and just for
reference
um R is currently ranked number 16 so
it's still it's still up there but it's
just not number one
right and python even though it's
number one in popularity the way it got
to its popularity is actually being
second best for pretty much everything
and so here's a response from Van
Lindberg who was the former General
counselor for the python software
Foundation he just stepped down uh
in April and even he had echoed this
statement about it's really like the
second best for everything if you don't
know where you're going in the future
Python's a prob pretty safe bet on in
terms of tooling
and so today I want to talk about
um how do we train a data set uh data
scientist in Python
and traditionally we've done things like
workshops
um this is generally my background of
teaching it's all coming from workshops
and then also what we've done in the
past is or what you've probably taken in
the past is stuff like an online course
and if you sort of think back on
your experiences with taking workshops
or online courses essentially if you
never got to use the work that you were
learning chances are you either retook
the same workshop on online course or
you sort of just let your knowledge
taper off
and that's something that we know can
happen we actually know a lot about
learning and this is one of the books
I'm currently reading right now uh which
is called how learning happens and it
consolidates a lot of the educational
literature into a single book and talks
about a lot of learning theory related
things I would say if you want to talk
about other resources and books about
learning like we can talk about it in Q
a as well
and then even internally at posit so
here's my uh supervisor Garrett
um we've taught workshops um from the
company's perspective and we've actually
taught them almost like too well
um and then even like myself like I've
taught workshops and my body of work is
um actually I've done this Workshop
teaching stuff for my dissertation work
so on the left hand side here here's an
example of what I would expect somebody
to get out of a short Workshop doing
Python and data science and so here's
like a script I want you to be able to
run I want you to be able to load some
data sets I want you to be able to
filter save out a data set for a to
start the process of a pipeline identify
how to process and clean data plot it
maybe fit a Eda exploratory model and
then look at its output and so there's
like seven things that I just mentioned
and what I found in even my own
dissertation work was if I took
your self-report on how confident you
are with those seven tasks I just asked
and I ask you pre-survey uh pre-workshop
after the workshop and then four months
out
um it actually turns out that like yes
workshops seem like they work
um everyone believes like they can do
all of these tasks and then essentially
for the four plus months out
um you can see like the response is
almost back to Baseline and it's because
like people it just seems like people
aren't really using this stuff even
though we put a lot of effort into
teaching this information
and so how do we come back this like
this one of the core principles that
we're trying to address here at Academy
and that notion of you taking a course
like a workshop or something short term
and forgetting it or having that
information Decay it's actually we we
know this is a known process something
that happens and so here is like the
forgetting curve where on the y-axis
here is you know arbitrary measurement
of your ability to master a topic
um and then the X represents uh time and
so usually right after you learn
something you you probably have a lot of
uh pretty high recall on what was being
taught
and then what ends up happening is if
you don't
um practice the task again you
essentially will forget slowly forget
the information that's being taught and
so one of the things and key components
here at Academy what we try to do is
put in regular points of feedback
or sorry regular points of practice just
so you can
re- bring back that information back to
you
and so you don't have to relearn
everything from scratch just a little
bump is enough to say oh yeah I remember
how this works and then we in Academy we
try to do this over and over and over
again up to the point where you've are
pretty much understand that material or
at least that's the goal and if you've
ever been in a scenario as you've been
learning something on your own and you
end up in a scenario where like I've
just been struggling trying to learn
this for like two or three weeks and
then like I can't really tell you why or
how it happened but like I read this one
sentence that I've been reading over and
over again and all of a sudden
everything clicked and so that's really
one of that's something that you can
notice about yourself and it's coming
from you reiterating and practicing and
rereading the materials and going
through the materials multiple times
and so there is a saying about like
neurons that fire together wired
together right so if we end up in a
situation where like we have two things
that were um that's just connected in
our brains and we focus on practicing
one set the part that we're practicing
will actually get strengthened and then
the part that we don't practice will
eventually fade off
and to the point where we eventually
might end up
um
learning a body of a material
and so again like that's one of the main
things that we're trying to do here in
Academy is
teach you a topic and then provide
regular points of practice for you to
achieve some type of mastery
and so just like with any skill
um you need practice but you also need
practice over time and so like you know
one of the analogies that we have in
um Academy is like it's very similar to
playing a musical instruments so like
I've also played the piano when I was a
kid and it's you do have to practice
this
um on a regular basis for you to just be
able to
um play a piece right and no matter how
well you are like I was terrible at
sight reading so I couldn't even fake it
when I showed up to class um anyway so
you really do need practice and practice
over time
and data science is one of those skills
that you again you need to practice it
and then you need some mechanism to
um kind of guide you over extended
period of time not just take like a
short-term
um block of
materials to learn and then sort of like
where do you go from there
so
what about online courses we've heard
about massive online open online courses
those usually run for multiple weeks as
well but the problem with moocs is uh
people the completion rate for moocs are
is very very poor and so people get
really excited especially if it's a very
popular and free class like everyone's
excited at the beginning and then over
you know a couple of weeks you know life
kicks in it just becomes really hard and
motivated to sort of just keep
um along with the actual course
and so that's the other thing that ends
up being really important is practice
does also require motivation and so what
we we try to Foster
internal and external motivation through
Academy as well and that's sort of the
reason why the group learning is a core
component of what makes Academy work
along with some other stuff that I'll
talk about in a bit as well
and so if we think about
um the traditional teaching format so I
just finished one term of uh a class and
I'm teaching a new one right now and I
putting together these slide decks I
just realized like yes the two courses
that I'm just teaching they're pretty
much taught in two different styles and
the one that I just ended up finishing
follows this more traditional model
where I haven't educate I as the
educator have information to give you as
the student
but then it's really like
up to the student to do the actual
learning and it actually takes a lot of
work on the students and to actually go
and master the information that I'm
trying to provide them
and you know I sort of realized um
putting together these slides like yeah
I actually just was one of the trainers
that actually fell into this trap of you
know being conveying information in One
Direction and then sort of like okay if
student needs help they'll come back to
me but at Academy we try to focus on
this actual Loop and be really explicit
about it and have the educator also be
part of that uh loop and that's sort of
why we've seen like a bunch of great
results over the last year with our
um when we first launched
and so how do we as humans actually
learn regular skills well there's also a
process for this that is
um that a lot of Industries and Fields
use like for example in medicine or any
of the uh skill based trainings um there
is apprenticeships internships
residencies or coaching
so how do we go and then apply that to
learning python for data science
well here's the key features of Academy
we have individually paced tutorials and
the tutorials are set in such a way
where they're supposed to be
they are you do need to spend time to
work through them it's typically under
an hour's worth of work in Total but
it's also small enough to reduce the
cognitive load on yourself as you're
going through the material so it's not
too much information at once
at the same time in Academy we have a
small group learning environment so
you're learning you have other people
that you're learning with so if you have
a question about something chances are
someone that you're learning with will
also have the same question because
you're going through the materials at
the same pace
and then you have people uh like myself
uh who are mentors and do the actual
mentoring and we sort of guide the ship
um to make sure that like you're
understanding
um the materials that we're providing
but also giving you the flexibility to
explore what you think is interesting to
yourself and sort of guiding you there
so you don't end up you know looking
into a method that isn't exactly what
you want or is making your life a little
bit more difficult so that's our role as
the mentor is to help facilitate your
learning
and the other really nice thing about
Academy
um to build on your motivation is we
have individual industry-specific data
sets for your projects so it's not like
a a complete cookie cutter for everyone
going through the experience depending
on the industry that you're in and the
vertical that you're in we will have a
data set for you in that industry it
might not be exactly the type of work
you're doing for your job right now but
it's close enough and that's also to
help bring a little bit more motivation
you might you know look at the data a
little bit differently you might try to
explore or try a new package or go down
another field that's something that we
didn't present to you explicitly but you
still have the resources to go learn on
your own and then the mentor sort of can
help guide that self-learning process as
well
so it's all about that long-term
engagement and all about okay so after
10 weeks can you still stick with the
skills that we're teaching you like the
actual skills of doing Python and data
science but also the skills of just
learning on your own
and so how does this actually look like
in practice well you have your Academy
Mentor so here's Brendan he's one of my
colleagues he'll play the role of a mock
Academy Mentor in this example and then
you have a small group of Academy
teammates typically right now it's all
in the same group so you'll notice that
the positions for these mock group mates
which in reality are also my co-workers
they are all roughly in the same work in
the same domain
and so as again as you're learning you
can have similar questions and you can
help each other out
and so here in this example you might
work on a project for Academy comparing
asthma treatments and this is something
that you'll work on over the course of
10 weeks so in this particular example
I'm showing you it's primarily in the
Life Sciences but again like I mentioned
we can swap out asthma treatments for
some other uh
vertical or some other domain and the
example a demo that I'll sort of show
you at the end shows you a stock pricing
example
um just to prove the point
and so what ends up happening is while
we go through the process well we're
teaching you data science the first word
of data Sciences data so how do we get
data in and so we'll show you how to
import data into pandas just so you have
your data frame that you can work with
then we go through and show you how to
explore data once you're done with
exploring you might go Wrangle and
visualize or do a little bit more data
processing and then at the end your
takeaway is going to be some type of
report using quarto for the python
course and that's what you'll end up at
the very end is this report that goes
through everything that you've worked
with over the last 10 weeks
so how do you go and accomplish this
project
there's a several key components and
I'll show you how all these bits and
pieces come together before I'll
actually show you a real demo of stuff
of what's going on
so we have our big project it's broken
up into 10 Progressive milestones and
the Milestones are kind of like
bite-sized pieces of a larger project
but we've broken it up into one week
components and this is one of the
mechanisms of getting you engaged over a
longer period of time and so it's
Academy is 10 weeks of actual working
time and then there's typically a couple
uh of weeks in the middle just as a
break or catch-up week as well
and so you have your Academy project
overall it has these five different
components so you'll import some data
explore for angle model and then at the
very very end in week 10 you put it all
together into a single quarto document
for a report that you can share with
your colleagues and that's sort of the
end goal is to have a data science
report that you can share
we take these overall components and
that's what the 10 Milestone pieces
become
and so in our python course these are
the actual 10 Milestone topics so we
have python Basics visualize create
select columns et cetera et cetera and
we have modeling and sharing reports at
the end
and I like to bring up like this is sort
of where the challenges of just teaching
data science for python starts to rear
uh come up because if our goal is to
teach you data science in Python just by
nature of how the data science Community
evolved and grew out of python there's a
lot of on-ramping like prior knowledge
that we need to be able to teach you for
you to be able to do and program the
data science in Python
and so the way we've handled this is we
sort of go through
um some of the basics in week one but we
still try to get you
um something that you can do by the end
of week one that is like the main like
um oh this is really exciting and the
way we do that is we sort of introduce a
little bit of the report stuff to you
maybe a little bit of figure generation
just so you are a little bit more
motivated to continue on and you have
something very tangible
and the other way that we've handled it
is like larger topics like just
visualizing
um and writing functions those are
pretty heavy uh Concepts and especially
writing uh functions um it's a very
heavy programming like basic programming
concept the way that we've solved that
problem is we take
um we introduce the concept in one week
and then over the next couple of weeks
we sort of smear out
um some of the more advanced topics as
well so one not only does that help you
engage with a more complex topic over a
long period of time but it also prevents
this notion that like oh I'm just in
week three and all of a sudden I feel
like I'm in my intro computer science
course again and
I'm no longer feeling like I'm making
forward progress towards like a data
science milestone
and so that's sort of the challenges
that we ended up facing while trying to
put together this curriculum and I think
this is something that seems to work
especially given the time constraints
and also if you think about what I
mentioned before about reducing
cognitive load or also not trying to
just dump everything on you because then
it's just too much information for you
to adequately retain and apply and so
there's always that balance there and I
think we figured out a pretty good
balance for that as well
okay so back to our Academy project
um it's composed of 10 milestones and
then for each of our Milestones you go
through a series of tutorials
after the series of tutorials you go and
finish that little Milestone chunk and
then what we end up doing is having a
group session where we all talk about
what we did for the Milestone and then
that's where a lot of the mentoring
guiding additional information and
active learning comes into play
so I've talked about group sessions this
is a big component of what makes Academy
special and I think it really enriches
the entire learning experience for
mentors and instructors and but also
really the learners
so the way this happens is we literally
meet up on a zoom call there's going to
be a milestone that's presented I will
actually demo a real life example
um at the very end and you as the
presenter you talk through what you did
and me as the mentor I tried really hard
not to share my screen or take over your
screen and we talk you through your
problems and so in some sense you're
also getting a feeling of what Care
Program feels like because I tell you
the line and what you need to type and
go through it I can Google things for
you in the background and tell you how
things work I can tell you what to
Google and point to you point to tell
you on the screen what you're looking at
and so it becomes a very uh you get some
experience with pair programming if
you've never experienced it before but
it's also like you are in control and I
don't want this to end up being like
another lecture it's supposed to be
guided towards what you need help with
and so again like we do this across
everyone in our group and so that's why
the group so far in Academy have been
relatively small and it's because we
need time for everyone to be able to
present their information and it um
there's a pretty good ratio between
students to uh mentors and I think right
now
um that ratio is around seven but we're
tinkering with bumping the ratio so I
don't know uh
exactly what's
um what the final number will end up
being if we do bump up the numbers
but the other really most important
thing is you're doing this in with your
group members and so that means that at
the end of The Academy experience you
have those connections that you took
this entire course with and so if you
have if you continue to use Python you
have other people that you can reach out
to after you're done with the academy
experience and because they've all
started in the same place you're more
likely to feel comfortable more
comfortable speaking and reaching out to
them because you've taken a course
together and we've literally shared
screens and we've all seen you know the
things that you've struggled with and
how you've gotten better so it all
um
it all helps your own motivation and it
makes you feel good that like you have
this other group of people that you can
reach out to because that's the other
thing a lot of times with learning new
things is you're just afraid or you
don't even know who to ask for help and
so we're trying to build that support
network in the course and then also
hopefully this is a network that stays
with you outside and that's another way
we try to engage you or keep you engaged
over long term and that's where the
learning really happens
and so your Academy project that comes
with multiple components for every given
week you go and do the tutorials you
complete and uh you personalize a
milestone and I'll again I'll show you
what that experience would be like at
the end of this uh portion
and then we present this to the group
and a lot of times people really do feel
like this is where a lot of the really
rich conversations happen
um sometimes depending on the learning
the experiences of the group
um we get to talk about more complicated
stuff and even if you're a brand new
beginner just seeing the more
complicated stuff knowing that it's
possible you know as a absolute beginner
that's really all you need to know is
that this is possible and then for
someone who's a little bit more
experienced they know how to actually go
and implement it and so there's I
actually prefer it when our small groups
have a mixed uh experience level only
because we get to have like just a more
Rich conversation for everyone to learn
from
and then in the middle of the week we
have a co-workers a co-working session
just so you have blocked off time where
the mentor is available to answer your
questions essentially like office hours
um from the University perspective and
then we have some form of asynchronous
communication like slack or Microsoft
teams and then if you post your
questions
um we can get back to you we can share
more complicated
um blocks of code or other resources to
help with your learning
and then that's just one week and then
you rinse and repeat do that for 10
weeks and then that is your your Academy
experience and so it is
um A Very Long Engagement but at the
same time that's sort of the point
because we've uh hopefully I've
convinced you that really if you're not
really engaged for a long period of time
one year the chances of you using the
materials is going to be low but you're
probably not using the materials because
you never fully understood or learned it
to begin with and so this is a reason
why the uh engagement and time
commitment is pretty high in Academy but
in reality it's not the worst thing in
the world it's just you're we're just
keeping you thinking about the materials
over at least 10 weeks it's not that you
have to uh it's not like this is like
another part-time jobs worth of
curriculum that you're trying to use so
we've scoped that material out
um as best as we can to make it light on
your normal work schedule
okay so I want to actually take you
through
um an example of what you will expect to
see there's going to be some screenshots
that I'll talk through and then at the
end I'll sort of uh mock up a sort of uh
user to Mentor interaction and that will
be in a in an actual live environment
so as of right now
um if you log into Academy this is
something that you'll see this is the
landing page and right now I'm going to
go through an example of Let's Pretend
We're in week four this week for
Milestone is about writing functions and
here are my four tutorials that we're
going to be talking about in this
particular week
I'm going to pretend I'm going to click
the write functions tutorial and this is
where the this is what the tutorials
actually look like in Academy so we
begin with a welcome statement to
contextualize the need for writing
functions in this particular example
and then we have a page the next slide
will end up being
things to think about before you
continue just so just to prime your mind
about like hey don't forget we're gonna
end up using this stuff
um don't forget this type of syntax and
notation
and then we start the lesson so yes
there is a bit of prose text involved in
getting the lesson started but
we then go into okay so here's functions
and here are parts of function behavior
and what it can do
and then right away we try to get you to
either see some code or run some code as
fast as possible so here in the
introduction phase the main goal of
we're trying to get you to write your
own custom functions well that's really
similar you've worked with functions
this entire time so here's an example of
a function you've seen before we're just
going to be able to instead of
random.random
write something that we've written
ourselves
the other thing that we try to do in
academy and this is one of the the
things that I find really interesting
when I first joined is we we don't hide
away from showing you error messages we
will literally put an error message in
the tutorial and then have you one see
the actual error message and then talk
to you about what the error message
means and then have you fix that error
message so here for example hey you're
calling random uniform in an incorrect
way this is the actual error message
that happens here's the actual code for
you to go and Tinker with to go and fix
it
and so again we're trying to break the
cycle of you reading a bunch of texts
and just clicking next because it's so
easy to do and so we put in these um
formative we either put in these
exercises or what's known as formative
assessments just to check that you've
actually grasped that little bit of
information that we're trying to convey
to you
and then
um literally the next thing that we end
up showing in this particular lesson is
oh here's a mock function that you um
that we can write and so this is just
code so then what we do is we break down
the code for you and tell you all of the
different components that end up
happening
and then from there we say okay let's
stop you from reading and let's get you
to do something again let's just run the
function that we just wrote and so here
this reiterates the process of hey
remember before when we worked with
random.random well that was a function
that just existed somewhere that you can
run but we just wrote this function
ourselves and you can run it yourself
just like every other function
and then the other style it's not that
we every single check-in or formative
assessment is going to be a coding
example even something as simple as a
multiple choice question or true and
false question that's really enough to
sort of get you to reiterate or that
little bit of practice of what's going
on and so here you see hey we're
actually calling the function object
itself and re-saving it we're not
actually calling uh telling the function
to run or call it we're just referring
to the actual object of the function and
so this is trying to connect or we're
trying to build the connections from the
earlier weeks of like remember how
variable assignments were working well
we can actually do the same thing with
the function if we never actually
um
um go about and
assign it to a variable
and so what we also end up doing in our
particular example is we add more
complexity by adding more input so
that's another thing that happens in
this particular tutorial
and then we have another set of
formative assessments so there is really
a pattern that's going on here is we try
our best to not have you blindly read
walls of text just to click continue uh
we really want to be very active in you
tinkering and playing with the code and
what's also neat
um that I I haven't shown it here in the
slides here but when you go and run some
of these assessments um we will show you
the error message if there is an actual
error message but if there's a problem
with your code or your result we try to
do our best and tell you what you might
have typed incorrectly in your code and
so it is sort of like this
um
like computer assisted
um helper if you want to think of it
that way it's not an AI tool um it's
actually looking at the results and
actually looking at the the text that
you're typing
um from the code to sort of give you
pointers in what went wrong
the other things that we end up doing is
we provide tips so not everything is
like a huge talking point that we want
to do and so we sometimes make little
call out boxes or like hey remember this
is an actual really important thing I
want you to remember so we do have
mechanisms to
um remind you of that information as
well
and then there's also some takeaways so
anytime there's like some weirdness with
the output that you might not expect
um we don't just brush it under the rug
we try to bring it up and just so you
understand what's going on and so we
have these different boxes and it's
mainly for like
additional information
um just so you know that we know that we
understand that what you see might not
be what you expect and this is why if
you understand it because you're a
little bit more advanced then great
you've uh you learned a new bit of
information but if you're a brand new
beginner it might be a little bit
overwhelming so that's also why we put
different boxes just to be like hey this
is just a little bit of optional
information if you don't understand this
you can bring this up with your Mentor
but just understand that like there's
other stuff going on but this is
something that might be useful to you in
the future
and the other thing that we try to do is
we try to be very realistic in how you
will end up building up code and testing
it yourself and then going back and sort
of like rewriting it in a more like uh
nicer correct way
um so this is an example of like hey
like yeah we didn't actually have to do
those con calculations in separate steps
we could have done all of those
calculations in one go and that's okay
as well
and then what ends up happening is
um you end up with another formative
assessment and
the question is like hey does this uh
code block actually produce an error and
then it really allows you the space up
here to explore and run the code
um to be able to answer this question
but we'll we also end up doing is
providing you the explanation if you
don't fully understand what's going on
we do provide you that information so in
this particular case we're trying to do
some set of calculations we never really
expected this to take a list of values
only single value so that's why there's
an error but we again in Academy style
we give you the place to actually see
the mistake and see the error message
because sometimes these error messages
do end up being very cryptic and so we
want the skill part of the skill that we
want you to have is learning how to read
these error messages
so I'll skip ahead in this particular
tutorial
um later on in this particular tutorial
we talk about uh Funk writing functions
with multiple parameters and so here
you'll see that like hey we've talked
about we've given you all of this
function code example let's slowly take
back bits and pieces of the code and
have you actively write it in yourself
right so from a very
super beginner point of view this is
really nice because you don't have to
worry about the calculation right now
this particular task is do you know how
to create a function with a particular
name and do you know how to provide
multiple inputs to a function that
you're writing we don't care about the
stuff down here right now I don't want
you to get bogged down with the
calculation I am currently only
concerned with the function signature
and so can you write that and so we
slowly will scaffold away code and just
to help build up build up the example
and again this is a way this is one
style or one method that we can reduce
the cognitive load of the learner as
they're going through this information
and so if you do something wrong here's
an example of like a piece of output
that is uh very custom and part of the
academy like software infrastructure
that tries to point to you like hey
maybe you did swap some values around
um and so that's one of the experiences
that you can get
and then the last example I'll skip
ahead again
um so here's an example of a more
summative piece of practice of like
let's incorporate everything that we've
learned and you'll see here like a lot
of the code is is gone and so there's
very little scaffolding happening
um and then if you go through more of
the exercises it just ends up being four
underscores for you um to be like write
your function from scratch right so it
really does guide you through and we
slowly take away key components
um for you to be one like you're very
active in this learning process you have
to go and type this stuff in in order to
progress to the next
um
I'm part of the tutorial
and then so when you're done with all of
that let's say I'm done with all of my
week's Milestone uh lessons I'll go and
create this uh go and run this actual uh
Milestone so I'll spend the time to go
do it and then we'll meet up at group
presentations and I'll talk about it and
so at this point I will go and demo an
actual uh what it might feel like as a
learner so right now currently I'll play
the role as a learner and I will say and
it'll be something like all right Daniel
you're up um let's talk about
um what you ended up going through today
so what I'll end up doing is like
and remember
um and if you're very new to python
um just know that like technically I'm
mocking up a week four experience so
there's might be some stuff if you're
very new to python that you might not
understand but that's sort of part of
the demo that I'm giving
all right so this is my week's uh
Milestone what I did was I loaded up all
of the stuff uh libraries that we needed
to run
and then the first part was to
um load up this data set so I used uh
the read underscore CSV function to read
in this indices data set and I saved it
to this variable called index
a little bit bigger
and then here they're task in the
Milestone
um it just asked me to like write a
function that if it took this as input
return this as output so this is the
function that I wrote I called it recode
symbol it took a thing called symbol and
then like if it matched all this stuff I
saved it to a variable and at the end I
returned this variable
and then later on in the uh assignment
it said like oh you just use this thing
so what I ended up doing was using that
function in apply to the symbols column
and then I got this new column down here
uh that recoded the variables
and then for uh my extension what did I
ended up doing was I wrote this function
right here that took the symbol that I
provided so this function took in a data
set a symbol I wanted a column that I
wanted and if there was a cutoff greater
or equal to that's what the data frame
returned so that's what I did it was a
uh piece of code that subset my data
frame and returned the subset of data
frame and I ran it like this so this was
my data frame and then at the end I got
fewer rows so that's what I expected at
the end
all right so that's something that's an
example of what a student will present
so I will like pretend I'm another in
person if I swapping out my glasses and
me as a mentor what would I do
what I would do is I would say it's like
hey Daniel that was great
um you got through all of the uh
replication bits of our Milestone so you
got the beginning bits
um so there's some things I kind of want
to talk to you about about your solution
so if you scroll down to where you wrote
the definition yes on line 56.
um you see here all of your if
statements
um the way you wrote this was if simple
is that set it to a variable and then
that's all great
um and we can see that your function is
behaving as expected the only thing
that's sort of not ideal about the
function that you're writing with is if
you remember the very first tutorial of
this week there was on if statements
um what's sort of missing in this
function is you using the L if statement
and the optional else statement in here
as well because the way your function is
written right now is it needs to go
through every single one of your if
statement checks right so if you had an
example you put in the symbol of carrot
DJI it would find this but it's still
going through and checking every single
other if statement and so in this
particular function that you wrote
probably not a huge performance issue
because it's a very simple calculation
but you can also Imagine like if this
was you know like a like a 500 million
rows this function uh the extra
calculation and time this function is
taking is going to add up and so ideally
I'll just do this I'll just tell you or
walk you through one of them right now
um so in line 61 if you turn that if
statement into LF
um you should be able to run that
function again and it should at least
behave properly and then the rest of
your code should be able to run just
like before and it seems like it is
right so you eventually want to
make all your if statements elif
statements just so it's not going and
checking every single one the way it is
going to be written now is the first
thing that returns true that's when it
will stop checking the the later
conditions below right and so it just
um
exits out of checking stuff a little bit
earlier and that could potentially save
you a lot of time
cool and then the other thing
um if you scroll down to your apply
example on line 87 yep so what you see
here is you use your function using
apply on that column called Simple so
that's great the only thing that's
missing right here is we wanted you to
um
create a new column called name and you
haven't done that so remember the way we
do that is we sort of pretend that the
column name always existed so you will
end up typing at the very beginning of
line 87 you'll type in indexes
and then you'll use a set of pair of
square brackets and then in there you'll
put in name
and then you'll set that equal to the
variable and then that way you get a new
column uh called indexes and the reason
why you're not seeing it is because
um
you just assign made a change to the
data frame so what you want to do is
maybe in a new chunk or below look at in
the at the indices data frame again so
if you scroll down after you rerun it
now you have the name column down there
and then everything with the extension
uh great job with uh going back and
reviewing some of our week two materials
and incorporating it into your function
all right so that's sort of an example
of what a um
Milestone session will feel like
um again like it's hard to mock this up
as one person but usually I'm saying all
of those words and then the learner is
actually typing
um so also part of that is to get them
get the muscle memory in for writing
those uh those bits of code the other
important thing of why I want the
learner to write it as well is because
they in the process of writing it will
also make typos and so you're also again
forcing them to see the error message of
the stuff that they're writing and a lot
of times if we have if we have time in
our group session I actually like let
them make the error and I just leave it
alone and then we talk about the error
that they typo that they made as well
all right so that's the demo so now the
question is like does this whole Academy
experience work uh the short answer is
yes it does so out of the 600 students
that we've gone through the academy
experience 95 have completed uh Academy
and then what's also really nice is I
think the denominator is 75 so 75 out of
75 people have said that they have been
using academy uh for work afterwards and
this is uh four to six months out I
think is the actual um cut off that we
use so
um we do have evidence that people are
sticking around
um and using the materials that we're
teaching them and hopefully it's from
the evidence-based learning
um
that is sort of making that happen and
it's not just us you know some people
um are talking about this online so
Keith uh finished uh with us through
Kellogg a couple of months ago and you
know he said
um this whole thing was a very great
experience
um and James Wade from Dow Chemical
Company is one of the uh people that
have repeat uh groups with us and you
and even they have reported that even
six months after 16 out of 17 say that
they still write code and speaking with
him a little bit more in detail about
that one person it's mainly because that
one person took on a more managerial
role so they're not coding as much so
things are things seem to be working uh
really well so with that I'll end here
and then sort of just uh take some
questions
yeah let's let's see if I've uh if I
queued up these questions correctly I
think I did but uh
good stuff
um
two questions off the bat that I saw got
upvoted in the slido kind of together
one's about pricing and one is about
individual learning paths um let me see
if I can share my screen
um
like wow that's like a lot
uh so pricing
um just in the interest of transparency
I think our pricing is like a few
thousand bucks per learner and it does
like scale and adjust depending on the
number of Learners so like really the
best way to get the most accurate
pricing is to talk with our team and for
us to understand what your situation is
but like a few thousand bucks is per
learner is
um the the quote that I think is like
reasonable to give and then like related
to individual learning tracks like the a
core part of the academy experience is
group learning like we believe in it
strongly
um so there aren't really individual
learning paths right now through the
academy experience that said some great
resources that we put out like the r for
data science I know it's not python but
R for data science
um the book is available online you can
see that we're kind of working on the
second edition highly recommend looking
into our posit conf
um workshops these are
um
Skilling workshops that we offer at
posicomp and you can see that there's
like a bunch of different sessions that
you can choose from like really good
content taught by experts about specific
things so that's like another option
then a little bit lighter like totally
free we have the data science hangout
every week Thursday you can add it to
our calendar add it to your calendar
join and like we'll just talk about
things related to data science so back
to uh you know your regularly scheduled
programming with questions about Academy
let me uh stop sharing my screen
uh and um
let me see if I can queue up these
questions
did that work yeah question does the
curriculum touch on environments
Daniel
um
can you ask that question again does the
curriculum touch on environments oh
um the actual curriculum does not touch
on environments like we use them
extensively just to get Academy working
um but we haven't really talked about
computational environments uh explicitly
in the 10-week program having said that
um depending on our interaction with you
your company might already have a uh
internal like connect server or
workbench server already set up
um we don't really
set up the environment for you but we
can the mentor can sometimes help guide
you through like setting up stuff like
that it'll definitely be more not in the
scope of the
um materials that we're teaching you but
if it's an environment related question
of the mentor might be able to help you
answer that but it's not something we
teach explicitly
all right next question uh
it looks like the code is running in a
browser does the course include help
with installing updating python or
running it in an IDE
a so we handle all of the installation
stuff for you
um we haven't the academy course does
not have a chapter on its own on just
getting everything installed for you
having said that I personally when I am
pointing people to the how do you
install python guide the posit Solutions
engineering folks
um has a guide out that uses Pi M and so
if you are
really looking into getting all of that
installed on your own computer locally
um that's sort of the set of guides that
I usually Point people towards but yeah
Academy is very scoped in the
um we have set up everything for you
um and then we'll teach you the
materials from there
um yes It's tricky because like
installation is very difficult but it's
also like that's one of those things
that like that could take potentially
all 10 weeks just to get your
computational environment working and so
and then you completely lose out on the
actual data science learning component
question what is the actual time
commitment per week for Academy
um the way we usually tell people is
about
um so each tutorial a lot one hour not
every tutorial takes one hour so it'll
be uh four hours for the tutorials spend
another hour on the actual Milestone so
that's five hours and then we have the
meeting once a week the group meeting so
that's another hour so that brings it to
six and then uh we have a working
session
um just so you block off time to do your
work so do you count that as part of the
tutorial or not I'm not sure but we'll
just add it to that so seven so
somewhere around like 10 hours I would
say is a pretty good estimate of how
much time you might end up spending
um in academy and then likewise and I've
seen it like you know there are people
who sort of try to go through all the
content the night before and try to cram
in your Milestone uh it happens life
happens but you you have to be careful
when that happened when you try to cram
in all that information because again
this is all about uh long-term retention
and not just you know getting things
done in the short term so if you plan
for 10 hours you should most likely be
okay and we work with
um if it's a business the business
interaction uh we do work with your
employer and your supervisors to make
sure that they know that you are going
through this process and it's not just
you working through this on your own
trying to find regular work hours for
you touched on this a bit in the
presentation what is the experience and
relationship like with the mentors I
don't know if you have anything to add
there
um
the I mean the mentors are pretty much
um we're available
um through uh slack for a lot of
questions that you might be having
um you do
depending on you know your own works
like NDA like you can't really talk to
us about your actual actual work and
your actual work data
um everything really does have to be in
the context of something you've seen in
Academy but if you
um Can mock up a work example
um and into a very simple question that
is relevant to what we're talking about
in Academy then those questions are
usually pretty valid that to ask your
Mentor so it's also a pretty uh informal
um very fluid and informal interaction
with your Mentor the more important
thing is your Mentor isn't really like a
traditional University instructor where
it's like I just show up and you just
expect me to lecture to you for you know
our group period it's really like you
have to come in show me what you've done
and then I point to you about how you
can make things better or you already
have questions for me about what you got
stuck in
foreign
intake process for Academy cohorts
that
um that is not something I personally
know about
um the onboarding I know it happens a
couple of months in advance there's
always legal documents that need to get
filled out and then there's also the
process of making sure everyone in the
group has some like agreement with
whoever they're working with that they
need time blocked off to make this
happen I've seen entire groups in a
company all together Join one Academy
cohort but I've also seen people scatter
across different departments join as a
group as well so
um but beyond that I don't know the
actual paperwork process
um but it's not like I want to do this
next week and you get it next week
There's I know that it's not like it's
not like that
yeah we'll we'll post there
full answer to that somewhere this was a
good question I want to make sure we get
to it uh do you have something for
advanced R users coming to python the
quote unquote false beginners
um we have
um is it Advanced our users coming
oh okay yes so what I've presented right
now is our first iteration of the uh
python course but yes we do plan on
having like a more
um like Advanced python stuff with a
little bit more of the programming
Concepts not just focus on data science
or data literacy principles
um the other and the reason for that or
why you should probably believe that
that's a true statement is we're also
currently in the works of creating like
an advanced R course as well and so the
python stuff is
um I'm on like the content writing teams
that we're sort of still refining the
intro one but as soon as that's done we
can write the next series of courses so
there will be more types of courses
happening in the future
um but I just don't know the actual time
table for those when those gets released
I think we have time for another
question or two and then we can wrap up
um
this is a good one I've seen academy
information about relevant curriculum
for certain industries could you expand
I know that you touched on that a little
already Daniel but yeah so what ends up
happening is the
um actual content stuff that you see so
let me scroll back uh so for example
this function writing tutorial this
tutorial is generic enough that it will
be what most or everyone will see what
we can do is in the actual Milestone
component the example that I demoed was
an actual stock pricing example but if
you're in life sciences and you want to
work on the cancer data set we would
swap out the Milestone uh portions for
that cancer data set so you don't have
to worry about like why do I care about
stock prices to write a function when I
work in healthcare or something you'll
actually get like a cancer tumor data
set for your Milestones so that's where
the customization comes in we work with
you figure out what your actual industry
is we have a a bunch of data sets in
different verticals and we will try to
find the right data set for you and then
we swap that into the Milestone as uh as
a way to keep everyone engaged and
things relevant
and I think we got through almost all
the questions uh one came in on the chat
have you thought about an academy for
training mentors
um yeah there is
um I
I can't say for sure but there is
something in terms of Mentor training
and stuff like that
um and occasionally I think we have uh
job postings looking for Academy mentors
as well so
um there is that process of
um becoming a mentor and then getting
some experience as a mentor running some
of these groups and that's all being
worked on
but I don't know what the actual when
the actual curriculum
um is is going to be finished
and then a final comment consider Julia
in the future please multiple
exclamation points yeah
um I'm sure it's being considered I just
know me personally I don't know Julia so
I I will not be able to be on that uh
content writing team but
um yeah especially with Corto having
um Python and R and Julia as an
observable as like
first
class support I'm sure it will be on the
docket but I can't there's no way I
can't put a date on that and I'm sure no
one on my team listening will want me to
say put an actual date on that
yeah so just uh we can wrap up we're at
the top of the hour
um
grid stuff that
one hour of awesome information just as
a reminder uh Academy for groups of
Learners lots of questions about like
self learning things again these
resources will package them up and send
them out somewhere but are for data
science the book
positcom we have you know Skilling
workshops from very beginner stuff to
more advanced stuff and please join the
data science hangout every Thursday at
noon for some more casual discussion but
we'll wrap up there as a reminder the
the presentation
let's see last time the presentation
will be available on YouTube like as of
now uh so if you want to send the
recording or watch it again it's
available about this link
uh we hope you join future sessions and
thanks a lot Daniel
thank you
[Music]